good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday that does not
feel like a monday because we have
things to do
we have to rise we have to grind we have
to chit chat
with one another because jackie's
finally back in new york back in studio
back at it again
i'm sorry with the white balance with
the white with the white
that trigger everybody and that's how
you know i'm back because the white
loafers are backing you know what
damn jackie back at it again with the
white loafers
yup that's me i can't believe you said
it doesn't feel like a monday because to
me
of all the mondays that have ever that
have ever
come across my desk today is the mondays
monday of all mondays you know what
this is going to be like an opposite day
kind of episode i'm feeling so
positive like maybe it's because you
went to that wedding so like i had
literally
off from thursday yeah so i'm so well
rested i actually didn't do anything
that crazy this weekend
i was very civilized i got tons of sleep
i did like took really good care of my
skin and my hair and like i got a new
hairstyle you didn't even comment
i was waiting for a gap in the co i was
waiting for a space in which i could
speak this is the same space always to
give compliments
i was going to and i was saving it
because you have this cute little
cute new little look going on and i
don't want to um
i don't want to say anything offensive
but the time that i last most recently
saw it was yesterday on my tv
watching love island okay so a lot of
people have been commenting on my new
hairstyle being like are you inspired by
lydia okay and so while she might be
wearing this haircut i didn't notice it
i saw this tick tock thing
okay where one of my favorite makeup
artists is artist nate well she does
hair too her name is erin
she did this thing where she did this
and then she took them and twisted and i
started to do it and i couldn't do the
twisty thing
but this was the first step and i'm like
this is cute it's really cute you're
looking so
cute today i just want to say like i did
not take it from olivia
okay i'm i just i really need that to go
on the record
i knew that you didn't i just wanted to
let you know that i did see it
on her no you're not the only person
like i got
millions of messages people being like
oh my god inspired by olivia like
no if you watch my stories last night
you know that i do not
stand with olivia yeah i understand and
i agree and i'm
pretty much caught up on lava island i'm
one episode behind
do you know what y'all saying no but i
was catching up skip it
skip it it was two hours long i'll tell
you you went home it was not even
exciting
the whole episode it was really like one
of those paramount plus specials like
they were playing they played a game the
whole time each of the girls
got like an undercover operation to do
whatever we have a really big tv recap
we have so much to talk about like where
do i even begin
i don't even know i don't know either
like
it's been so long since we podcasted
first of all well we podcasted on
wednesday so i guess that's like
and it's been so long since we've been
in studio right and i just i feel like i
have to catch you guys all
up how was your weekend where did you go
what did you do
my weekend was so wonderful i was at
blackberry farm for a wedding my friend
jess and it was such an amazing
beautiful weekend beautiful couple like
everything was just
so beautiful and i was with dana because
um we met jess on birthright and dana
and i went on birthday together i
didn't realize we have your birthright
friends right isn't that so fun
wow gotta go on birthright so somebody i
know can get married at blackberry farm
so we can spend the weekend there
booking a trip literally also like this
is your sign to go on birthright because
it's literally
lifelong friends and dana and i were
just like reminiscing on birthright the
whole time and
it just it was so much fun no it was
birthright it's like a rite of pa
it's a birthright for like you know jews
who grew up on long island
but actually that's not true everyone
from all around the world it's all jews
and even i think i don't know what the
minimum amount of jewishness you have to
have i think you could meet
a quarter jewish yeah but the thing is
is like just
the kind of makeup of the trip is
torture it's really like the antithesis
of who i am as a person it's
lots of hikes and bus rides and early
mornings and museums
museums and like you know boxed food and
personally i just i think it's so
important to know your body and more
importantly to know your limits
and i drew a line in the sand i'm not
even eligible but like at a point in my
life i was eligible
but i just knew it's something i would
deeply regret
not the experience or the knowledge but
the the journey
yes everything about birthright like the
schedule you are jam-packed and
we dana and i actually went on a trip um
with
the oldest group possible we went when
we were 24 which is actually old for
birthright most people go in high school
and it is weird to have so much
structure
when you're an adult and it's like
you're on a field trip and it's like
but i'm 24. you know i like to get these
pockets of free time and it's just like
why aren't i just in israel doing my
thing but like you know what you
it's so worthwhile and you do things
that you would not bring yourself to go
and do but you learn so much and it's
just such a great experience and they
they really have it like down pat you
know and he made friends to last a
lifetime
and we made friends to last a lifetime
and you got invited to blackberry farm
so i think it's a win-win-win and so it
was so nice to celebrate
how was the facility the grass the
facilities were so
sickening they were so amazing they were
it was camp
did you say it was bucolic bucolic farm
chemin it was sickening the barns down
the barn it was so campy like ac
was peaking it was camp as in nature not
camp as in
high fashion right but actually some of
them were that would have been a good
caption some of us brought the camp to
camp some of us did
um ben literally in the car and i was
like do you see jackie she looks amazing
he's like
yeah how did she pack that dress i'm
like actually i'm so glad you asked
we have a patreon vlog she did her
entire packing journey on our patreon
like you should check it out if you're
really curious
you should check it out and took up like
my whole luggage which is why i didn't
have any clothes for the rest of the
trip which is why i barely posted on
instagram because i was wearing the same
thing over and over again
but i will say i didn't check luggage
because our flights
we had a connecting flight and there was
just a lot going on we flew an airline i
never flew before and i was just like i
don't want to leave anything to chance
what airline have you never flown
allegiant from florida
to knoxville it's like a regional
airline right you've probably never even
heard of it so i was just like i don't
know how allegiant
does how their bad carrying skills are
right so i was like i don't want to
leave anything to chance i don't want to
lose this dress and like ruin my weekend
so we're not going to check luggage and
when i tell you about my travel day
yesterday
i don't know how we would have gotten
home if you had checked about because we
would have been
stuck and i'll tell you about it in one
second but i just want to say blackberry
farm was
so amazing and it was all it was so camp
but it was also so wellness focused like
friday we did like massage did you find
yourself going back to your pritikin
best self
i i really did it was like a mini
retreat which
i always can use always and i was so
relaxed dana and i we just like love to
like sit in pretty places and read
so we were in actual heaven it was such
a wonderful weekend i was you know
so excited to come home just because of
brew or
of course honestly being away from brew
really threatened to ruin my entire trip
i was
like low-key depressed the whole time
welcome to the mom life
it was so so hard i couldn't think about
him too much because i would get
emotional but i couldn't stop thinking
about it of course
it was so difficult like oh my god it's
a true deandra's choice
to think or not to think to vacate or to
be with brew
so true be with brew anyways yesterday
so we blackberry farm is in knoxville so
yesterday we had a connecting flight
knoxville to atlanta atlanta
to newark we took the 8 50 a.m fight
because we're like that gets us
that gets us home by 12. so we left the
premises at 6 45
to make our flight we get on the plane
everything seems to be going smoothly
there's
there's something broken always we're
sitting on the plane i fall asleep on
the plane i wake up on the plane we're
still on the ground
that's the [ __ ] worst and like you
can see in the front like everyone
pretending to do stuff like talking
about it
they keep saying you know we're gonna
try to reset the system like you're
going to unplug it and plug it back in
no also it's like
in those situations you really want to
get off the ground but then it's like
you're working with like a rebooted
plane like is this it's like you don't
know what you want
to get in the air and like probably go
down or just sit on the tarmac like i
truly don't know what's worse no and i
said like they should let us know what's
wrong with the plane and we can we
should decide
we should vote is it something and if
you're not comfortable is it something
we can live with
right is it an air conditioning issue
right you know or is it you know
one of the wheels won't go down right or
like an engine it's not on
right how i agree like how
dramatic is it because i've been on
flights before you get delayed because
the bathroom
the toilet's not working someone's seat
belt doesn't work it's like just get off
the plane
like take take one for the team no i
agree sometimes it's like minutia that
delays a plane and it's like
this is what we've been sitting around
for yeah so unclear what the issue was
they kept saying it's a control issue
they were giving us nothing
and i'm pretty sure they were just going
through the motions and they knew this
plane was never taking off
so after about two hours on the plane
where we already like would have been in
atlanta whatever
they deplane us and we what's worse than
the shame of reverse
planing like oh my god you're like
you're so lost and you're so hopeless
yeah we realize we're not getting
anywhere on this plane because they
can't figure this out like
it's just not happening our best chance
is getting a new plane
but we're in knoxville like nobody's
respecting this little flight from
knoxville to atlanta and there's not
just like a million flights
oh let me just hop on this united like
no and it's not a major hub
the plane that we need like is coming
from atlanta yeah so
we were it was i was with zach dana and
her fiance josh and we were just like we
need a plan
we had booked backup flights because we
were already missed our connecting but
there was no there was no plan in place
for this flight i hate a plan less
flight
and it's a really small airport with not
a lot of options so they have good food
um no but it was it was still really
early actually they had like no food
because then
we decided to rent a car to drive to
nashville and take a flight from
nashville to jfk
who drove josh drove thank god for josh
and i was that's when i got hungry we
stopped at duncan and you know duncan
sometimes is i love duncan in general
but sometimes it's hit or miss they do
have they have a quality controller they
do it's like each franchisee like just
decides whether they want to take a [ __ ]
in the food
or they don't totally like do they want
to use yesterday's donuts or make fresh
ones today like there's
such quality control issues i couldn't
agree more like you can get the same
thing at four different duncans and
they'll be different colors no i got
i got my duncan order like i love
dunking when i need a breakfast fast
food item because i get those egg and
cheese wraps
maybe a few assorted munchkins a coffee
oh assorted munchkins
and when we were coming back from the
hamptons a few weeks ago we stopped at a
duncan that was
poison literally poison and you know
what i was
i was feeling kind of like
ptsd when we pulled up to this duncan i
was like what am i gonna get i ordered
so much stuff because i was like
it's so hit or miss rolling up to a
dunkin is like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
it's like a box of munchkins
but you do know what you're going to get
because they all look different yeah i
guess unless you just put your hand in
oh yes unless you're blind for sure
anyways we roll up to duncan we ordered
the feast
and it was delicious it was just what we
needed fueled us up even the coffee was
good which is
good that was so surprising so we fueled
up egg and cheese wraps were so good i
did ask for a sword in munchkins and
they definitely gave me the least
popular flavors they didn't even give me
a glaze
okay here's another ten that's a great
question i asked for ten they gave me
because i was like do your thing the
guys
are you like keeping the excel
spreadsheet of the donuts i i had to
recount it to the group and you know i
have a good memory
there was four blueberry oh what nerve
four chocolate so good the most and then
two powdered
nobody even touched a powdered in your
opinion
of the tradition i'm not talking about
like the new blueberry the traditional
munchkins what is the best flavor glazed
and then
chocolate i guess yeah me too but like
that wasn't an assortment when you just
give me three and one of them is like
your special flavor but also do not
write off the jelly filled
i don't even know if it was jelly filled
we didn't even get to it no not powder
jelly filled glazed jelly filled oh
interesting interesting
so duncan fueled us up we drove to
nashville we realized on the way that
we're driving through a time difference
and we were like oh my god do we gain or
lose an hour that wait because nashville
is central time and knoxville
was eastern time you're curious when we
go to
nashville it goes one hour back yeah of
course i know that but you're saying in
the same state
in the same state so in knoxville it was
eastern time and we drove west towards
nashville and we
entered a new time zone wait i'm sorry
i'm just really struggling i really want
you to get to the end of your story but
like
i'm really struggling with this new
piece of information i'm just learning
there's
two different time zones in one state i
think in a lot of states they have
different twisted
twisted wha who thought that would be
helpful no and it's like we had to do
quick math
and it turned out that we gained an hour
of travel time which was good but if it
had been like the other yeah
we would have missed the flight and we
wouldn't have realized we'd be driving
towards nothing oh my god
stop i would have been so confused like
yeah it was really confusing and the car
clock didn't change i had to like
manually change it because we were
getting like so mixed up
that's turned so we get to nashville
honestly the drive was like pretty
pleasant like tennessee is just like so
stunning and luckily like no one had to
pee or anything we were just like all
enjoying our dunkin
and we made it and we got to nashville
and we got to the gate we had like about
an hour before we boarded and we boarded
and the plane took off
and did you shed a tear it was so
beautiful can you believe
yes i mean i actually i don't think and
that is why
i did not want to check a bag because if
we were waiting for our knoxville flight
how do you get your bags off you can
check that you can't
this is we would have had no agency in
the situation and we kept checking that
knoxville flight and i don't know if it
ever took off
when we landed it still hadn't taken off
the thing is that i personally would
never have found myself in that
particular situation because i'm
always the one to opt to fly into the
major airport
and take a longer car ride like i went
to
morocco and we were going to marrakech
but you fly into casablanca and then you
drive three hours to marrakech now some
people took the connecting flight we
were all going to the same wedding
everyone on the flight was like going in
the same wedding yeah so some people
took the one hour flight and some people
took the three-hour drive
and we all got there at the same time
and i just had to sit in a car for three
hours
so i just have to say this is your sign
always go to the bigger airport and then
take a car
like flying into nashville and driving
was not an option for anyone because
there was like a perfectly good
airport 30 minutes from blackberry farm
and i will say when we booked our
flights a few months ago for this trip
new york to knoxville was a one-way trip
and then delta you know when all their
shortages
and all these airlines by the way the
airlines are out of control what's going
on there
i know but delta said this is no longer
a route you're now
flying through detroit next day you're
flying through atlanta
every every day they kept changing the
flights so we got what we got and
and i had been dreading this two-stop
flight
ever since they moved the flights to
shops and it was worse than i could have
imagined no i'm actually nervous because
i have like a similar adventure coming
up i'm going to tully ride
which in the winter is very easy to get
to in the summer it's a one-stop shop
yeah because it's a ski destination are
there any days of the week
no no are you sure it's a winter and
trust me there's not one day of the week
where there's one where there's non-stop
there might be there might be but i
can't go like what i'm gonna go on
monday the wedding's not till sunday
i have the work to do bring your
microphone but like bring your
microphone
i worked so hard to find like i embraced
my inner points girl and i found a
flight with
lay flatbeds on the way there and then
there's like the 30 minute flight like
two montros
so you don't want to drive from the
major airport it's six hours
that's where i draw the line that's why
i'm saying i'm like in a similar
predicament
it's like an hour flight night okay okay
um it's just really long like trust me i
looked into all
all possible journeys and i'm just now
that
i mean obviously things aren't back to
normal but like people are traveling
again and it's like
i kind of didn't miss this part you know
no no i'm
cured for life i'll be sitting in this
chair for the next
10 years never going anywhere again
every time i travel and like mostly i
have a negative experience like pretty
much all the time like i swear to myself
i'm like i'm never traveling again but
then it's like
the thirst for adventure the wanderlust
oh the watch gets to
girl at heart you can't i had a dream i
killed the points guy murdered like
hardcore it wasn't an accident like
murder and he buried his body and then
like the first degree
yeah the investigation was like getting
really close to me and like i knew my
time was up
and i just like felt so sad that like i
killed my friend i was like so sad for
his parents like
so sad like for my social life like
there was just so many elements too it
was really a terrible dream
so you must have been glad to wake up no
wonder you're in a good mood today oh
and part of the reason i wanted to say i
was in a good mood today is i changed my
alarm i moved back 30 more minutes just
to give myself a little bit more grace
snooze time no not even to snooze just
to like like slower
up moved it back okay okay just to like
move slower
and like take my time like i [ __ ] up
my makeup on my foundation i just
started over because like i had time
and i think i'm going to keep that i was
really inspired by margaret like she
wakes up at 6 30 to work out
i'm not that extreme i just needed to
wake up like a little bit earlier just
to like
enjoy my morning instead of like
literally looking in the mirror and like
hating myself you know yeah i did have a
long morning too i woke up like way
before my alarm because i went to sleep
like an hour
earlier due to the long day she fell
asleep early yeah
but i actually feel more rested the
other way when i sleep as long as i
possibly can
but you know what no i don't you gotta
switch it up you would think like more
time
equals more energy but no i think like
just
being rushed and like hating the way you
look like that ruins my day
yeah you know what i mean yeah like i
had time to do my tick tock inspired not
olivia
inspired hair and like i'm just feeling
myself you know yeah and i i want to
radiate that energy for everyone feel
yourselves on these but this monday
feel it even though like it literally
looks like it's midnight here in our
studio because the sun just like is gone
and the scaffolding is just enclosing us
in darkness
we're still here to be bright and shiny
it is technically morning we didn't just
record at night it's not the midnight
toast and pass it off yeah no no it's
fully
august 10th i have no idea yeah i think
it is that's crazy
that doesn't sound right no it is august
9th okay oh my god single digits
there's a difference for sure there's a
difference though i was
i just like got randomly so excited for
fall this morning
that's so weird that you said that
because you know how like your phone
does like on this day and like i clicked
it and one of the pictures was just me
and like a sickening fall
look and i was just like they don't it's
not on this day by the way
just so you know my honest day is just
like oh on your photos app
yeah yes it's just not on this it's not
on the days random pics you might want
to see
totally i thought you meant timehop
which is very accurate very
to the minute no
so the picture that came up today was
just like you know one of my sickening
fall fendi looks and i'm just really
excited to getting back to being her
because august jackie o is nothing of
the sort that's so funny i was having a
similar conversation with ben yesterday
because like i'm so looking forward to
the holidays
and i remember last christmas being it
was snowing and i'm like
christmas i remember saying to ben or
like no i actually said it to myself i
said next christmas like i want to be in
a different apartment because like i
live in a bunker with no windows
and i can't see the snow and i'm like
and now i'm like it's august and i'm
like still in the apartment like i'm
making them like i will not be in this
apartment by christmas i want to see the
snow like
i just like i need i need a shift in
energy you know like yeah even the best
apartments after a while just become
somehow like toxic places i completely
agree and i've reached my toxicity limit
like i'm so
ready to move you know what we should do
we should apartment swap for like a week
what do you think sure except i mean
like i said i have a question to bring
all my [ __ ] up no
but like i feel like you you know
you just need to like get outside new
perspective like i love your apartment i
think you like mine
yeah of course no i just think like when
you're in a
space that no longer serves you
it can be very mentally taxing i'm being
dead [ __ ] serious
i completely it can really contribute to
like anxiety and seizing like i really
believe that it has a true
impact on your mental state and i feel
like i'm now at a place where my
apartment no longer serves me mentally
or physically and if i don't see the
snow this christmas like i
i know it sounds weird it sounds like a
hallmark movie thing but like if i don't
see the snow this christmas like
i'm done it does sound like a good plot
for a home everybody like will she move
before christmas no i know and then she
like moves in and the snow's falling
down
and it's not for lottie mom this is
beautiful
exactly like that's what i want like i'm
gonna get my ass a christmas tree like
for sure like that's how
that's how convinced i am but i just
want to say it's not for lack of trying
like i'm
the fact that i didn't move during the
pandemic like literally haunts me at
night because
everyone thought like this was an
apocalyptic state and like rent was
literally down by 50
it was so cheap and there was one in my
building and it was just like a little
too much money and now i'm like you dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] like just spend the money
fat ugly [ __ ] like i'm so mad at myself
like not a day goes by that i don't
think about like not taking that
apartment in my own building like
and everyone moved who like stayed in
the city and like got such great deals
and now it's literally like
highest rent since the
dawn of time and it's not for lack
there's no inventory like i check
every day and it's just like what i want
i can't afford and it's like until then
i just need to work harder
is the apartment in your building still
available no i literally email the
realtor every day i'm like hey i'm still
here if you're looking for a tenant
damn yeah it's so upsetting sometimes
you have to learn the hard way
and it's so hard i know but sometimes i
still think about the apartment and like
it was too much money like
i stand by that really it was more than
like you would put into your search
criteria
now no but like the thing is and i was
talking about with ben
like i am so fiscally responsible when
it comes to my rent
and nothing else like also you need like
you should loosen up a little bit
because your apartment is where you
spend all of your time it's where you
work it's where ben works it's where
theo works and like it's not just like
you're one of those new york city people
it's like it's just a place to salute
no it's not it's a place to literally
exist yeah no
no i know so i'm like why am i so and i
just have like a really good apartment
right now for like
so little it's like i can't believe how
little i pay it's like so fabulous
but like i think i need to like
like i'm constantly like spending money
like it's nobody's business but like
not on the thing that matters most my
home that matters most where you spend i
would say 95 percent of your time 97
yeah so that's what i'm currently
working with and just like keep me on
track i need you guys to keep me
accountable like i will see the snow at
christmas like i
will okay i will that's exciting i mean
i
i think moving is just so much fun and
so exciting and i think changing i also
just want like outdoor space like i just
i need to elevate out here
crazy really i don't know i mean you
don't get it all i know and like i just
don't want a balcony like i want a
full-blown like
terrace yeah no out of control like a
wraparound
just like no i'm fully out of control um
okay cool well i'll look for you that's
like a fun time
it's like i know zack is always on
street easy like he's been sending me
links
none of them are working currently but
like keep it coming okay cool cool
that's exciting yeah so that's the
journey like i'm currently on
nice well now that in addition to
watching literally every single
piece of television that ever existed
that i can't wait to talk about in the
tv recap i don't know how you do it
oh my god no like that's why i was
excited to like that's why i'm not
dreading this monday i have so much to
talk about love is blind
after the altar love love island obx i
won't spoil it but like
white lotus like i just watched
everything on planet earth what did you
think about white lotus
i'm like two episodes behind so don't
spoil anything hate
right okay no i'm only on like episode
two i'm not even gonna finish it me and
ben cannot get through we're just like
looking at each other we're like why
isn't this show good it's
so slow but like connie britain's
amazing the cast is amazingly pleasing
interesting premise it's like murder on
the orient like what happens it's
atrocious
yeah i said the same thing we're so in
the minority i couldn't put my finger on
it but i will say so i think i watched
three episodes and
i haven't watched last night or the week
before and i'm kind of like looking
forward to just
to watching it more just because it's
it's not unenjoyable
um and maybe it just goes to like show
the state the low state of content these
days so that's what but you know it's
not there's so much good tv on
so i'm like this is what everyone's
raving about when i first started i'm
like oh my god
stunning this connie britain
is really like girls the cast it's like
this is great and then it just
jennifer coolidge you saw his testicles
i know
i can't believe that didn't go viral on
tick-tock no totally and i was just
like jennifer coolidge but like what is
she doing
i don't know like she's being such a
freak i just i couldn't believe that
that's maybe an unpopular opinion
but i just couldn't believe that this
was the show everyone was like felling
over yeah no i agree with you that was
my takeaway also
okay but i am going to keep watching it
just i might
it was good enough so now that we're all
caught up without further
do it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
manly bands after countless hours spent
jumping through jewelry store hoops in
search of the engagement ring of your
dreams
the last thing your man wants to do is
run to the same gauntlet again for his
wedding band
now thanks to manly bands he doesn't
have to a truly a godsend for brides and
grooms alike
manly bands has awesome wedding bands in
just about every type of earthy material
imaginable even from space so ben
like has been on a journey with his
engagement ring he's lost it
three times because like they don't
really properly fit and they're just
like he's always twisting it it's just
like not conducive for a manly man like
ben
that's why manly bands has been just
like a true godsend because they're so
customizable
material color quality super customized
customized to get started have your man
order the manly ring sizer from manly
bands to ensure that his ring will fit
perfect during the work
and the play so it won't fall off at
soho house
once he knows his size it's time for the
fun part manly bands has an insane
selection of materials to choose from
like gold wood
antler steel dinosaur bone and even the
meteorites that killed them
he can also choose from curated
collections like the jack daniel's
whiskey barrel collection
and if he's feeling more creative he can
customize his band from scratch choosing
the style material
in life sleeve and finish once he's
selected his band manly bands offers
free shipping worldwide
and a 30-day exchange policy with free
warranty so while there might be a 50
chance of your marriage working out
there's a 100 chance that he's going to
love his band
to order his manly band to get 21 off
plus a free silicone ring
go to manlybands.com toast that's
manlybands.com
toast for 21 off manly bands the best
damn rings
period thank you for that claudia now
our first story is actually our
final olympics recap the tokyo
olympic games of 2020 held in 2021
are officially a wrap they had the
closing ceremonies they passed the baton
to paris for the 2024 games i love how
like no one watches the closing
ceremonies
yeah and they said that's that on that
but the uh
nbc olympics did have a jonas brothers
performance of remember this
which is the official song of the
olympics and it was unbelievably
stunning
it wasn't live or anything but it was
still gorgeous i'm gonna have to check
that out oh that's like a
that's a song yeah it's definitely a
song
i'm really looking forward to checking
that out it was really good also the
final medal count is
in and the us has eked
out their win 39. slim slim
slim by the hair on our chinny chin chin
39 gold medals for the u.s to china's 38
japan 27 great britain 22
roc 20 and in the overall metal count
the us had 113 china had 88
japan had 58 great britain had 65 and
the roc had 71.
i mean it was touch and go there for a
minute because like china was really
ahead of us in the gold medals we were
never going to lose the overall like we
were ahead the whole time
but the gold medals is equally as
important and we were like
really behind um and a couple people
pulled it out and i just think they
deserve a shout out
the indoor women's volleyball team
for the first time i think ever won of
course men's basketball won and of
course
women's basketball one and i just found
out that like the queen of the women's
basketball team sue bird who i thought
ben might be in love with
she is married or dating to meg rapino
from the soccer team no way
there's no way ben can get in there
thank god
and then also the women's beach
volleyball duo team
the a team filled with toasters
won thank god so like that's when we
really started to like ramp up on china
like the basketball the indoor sports
like
we really just like cinched it and it
was i'm so grateful like
to every single gold medal winner for
taking us there
yes really exciting and also i'm just
curious so clearly like the u.s won the
olympics because we won in both
categories
but say china won gold medal count and
we won overall
who won the olympics the person who wins
overall i think i mean there's no winner
like there's no i mean the whole thing
is about gold silver and bronze and then
you're gonna say there's no
winner yeah i do feel like it's weird
that there's not an official winner by
country in terms of meadow count just
because it is such a competitive
competition um but there's not so like
there really is no
considered there's no winner considered
i think that that
is a mistake like there should be of all
the olympics like
you know 2014 the winner was actually
that wasn't in
no kind of how like there's all these
international competitions like
eurovision there's a winner
um world cup world cup yeah no for sure
it's kind of weird it's like they
they brought it all the way to the end
zone but it's not across the line no
that's a really good point but like in
my mind i've always like
tallied up the winner in my head but
it's not an official winner yeah
interesting really interesting but i'm
glad to know that again there's no
you know confusion and we don't have to
duke it out oh my god alona
follow mantic talk she's like this
woman's rugby player who went
like she has like millions of tick tock
followers because she was like
tick-tocking through the olympic village
and one of her videos came up on my free
page and said follows you and i was like
what lona mar follows me
so yeah i'm just like kind of like an
olympic influencer that's really cool
but we already knew that
yeah no like not me facetiming drunk
with olympians in my bathroom
i actually spoke to emma coburn i forgot
to mention um about our facetime because
the last time we podcasted i don't know
if you guys listened
i was really kind of anxious about like
getting blackout drunk and facetiming in
olympian
and i wasn't even sure if she knew i was
drunk because she thought this was like
i was just like a weird person sober
and she said she definitely knew and
that she loved it so like thank god oh
my god i told you
yeah no i had nothing to worry about
that's so exciting it really is
so that's out on that on the olympics
this has been really fun
uh the good news is is that the next
olympics are in less than six months
so we have that to look forward to and
you know what i can't remember i don't
think i've ever
watched the winter olympics since being
a very proficient skier
and so now i'm really excited to watch
because i think i'll have more
skin in the game you know what once i
said
like once the olympics are over i will
be like depressed
and i thought i was gonna be but i have
i can't lie
i'm curious if other people felt this
way i felt very overwhelmed yeah between
just like all the tv that's already on
like love island being on
every night all the real housewives like
there was so much tv to watch
and then the olympics which were on 24
7. yeah
i felt very overwhelmed and not in a fun
way like in the beginning i was like
this is fun i'm overwhelmed
but then i'm like this is not fun i'm
not overwhelmed so now that the olympics
are over i just want to say i'm not as
devastated as i thought i would be like
i don't have fomo like i'm actually
relieved
yeah i think you got your olympics fix
yeah and the fact that there's another
one six months away like i'm already
feeling like
choked overwhelmed yeah but it's so
exciting you'll be in your new apartment
i better be the snow falling watching
the ice skating i better be so when is
the
what is it january six months it's
august
february 8 plus 6 14 february
cool see you in february yeah i'll
definitely be in my new digs
yeah that's exciting yeah new spot come
through
i'll be there okay so we're officially
we're officially putting it to bed
closing the book closing the chat
it's a chapter because the olympics
aren't like over forever closing the
chapter
on the olympics and if you're looking
for a great chapter to read head over to
amazon and check out my new york times
bestselling book
girl with no job the crazy beautiful
life of an instagram thirst monster
written by me it's about 240 pages and
if you buy the hard copy you get
pictures in the middle so pictures are
great
thank you for that claudia speaking of
books oh my god i'm so sorry that's like
dropping the bible
no i'm kidding that was a joke speaking
of books um
new redheads episode is coming out on
thursday i've been reading the book i'm
almost done with it
it's so good and so cute and like it
really has a camper counselor vibe if
you really look into it
um between the lines uh clara and the
sun by kazuo ishiguro and it's really
a quick read and i'm just real i'm
really looking forward to seeing what
happens i have no idea where it's taking
me
but i'm enjoying the ride it's kind of
has like a black
mirror vibe oh sorry stay away but
nothing spooky
nothing stay away i don't want nothing
spooky
i will never it reminds me of the
episode the ashley oh episode most
i will never ever watch our show again
i mean you guys know why you guys know
why stop go away
we're not even on eps it's story two
you're not gonna ruin the show go to
stream
are you ready for story time is it about
the prime minister
but i was like i can't even speak it i
can't speak it into
next story jessie j apologizes to nicki
minaj over bang bang mix up seven years
after the song's release
this is something
it is seven years after the jessie j
ariana grande nicki minaj collab bang
bang popped on the charts the trio song
is making and changed the world
and changed the world and just gave us
so much that we didn't even deserve at
the time and i feel like now seven years
later it's just like i can't believe we
even had that
no and now it's like finding out that
literally everyone involved in the song
like hates it
um i don't know it's just like it's
crushing
it is it turns out that jessie j and
nicki minaj remember the beginnings of
the
single a little differently and minaj
called out jessie j's version of the
story which the singer had discussed in
a recent interview with glamour on
friday
as jesse j recalled she said quote nikki
was plated in the studio and was like
i've gotta jump on this
we didn't go to her and ask she wanted
to do it but according to nikki who
responded to justin
by the way jessie j was like and that
was like the honor of a lifetime like i
remember being in my apartment hearing
her verse and thinking like how is this
my life like it was a very
complimentary conversation in the
interview but according to nikki who
responded to jesse's quotes on thursday
with a correction
i didn't hear the song and asked to get
on it the label asked me to get on it
and paid me
she tweeted how would i have heard the
song
sorry this billboard is just all ads
everywhere
um she so she said that they
paid it paid her for the song and she
didn't hear the song before
and she like kind of took it as an
insult that like nikki would hear a song
and want to jump on it she was very
defensive
yeah she but for what it's worth she did
want to get on jessie j stone do it like
a dude after catching it on the radio
she said but the worst part about this
no one ever asked me she tweeted with
laughing face emojis
i have been obsessed with that song
since the minute i heard it because then
in jessie j's
um follow-up she's talking about do it
like a dude and i was like where does
that come into play
okay well i'm just focused on the bang
bang because i just feel like
oh wait and then jessie j responded and
like she on friday she apologized to
nikki over the confusion about
bang bang she came to be with a meme
filled lengthy post on instagram writing
i respect you publicly being yourself at
nikki so here i am being myself this is
a video of me back in 2015
on stage taking the place out of myself
which is basically an hour of my set
it was made into a meme about two weeks
ago was that what this is really about
and where
this weird energy began between us began
i don't understand jesse's
no okay at all video of jessie j like
while the song is playing it's nikki's
part and it it seems she's like
mouthing it but not really she's just
kind of like i guess quote taking the
piss out of herself
i don't know oh jessie's response made
no [ __ ] maybe mickey saw that video
and got offended by it
um and then she said or maybe it was
when you used me as a stair rail at the
amas so there's like a meme of
nikki walking down the stairs and
holding on to jessie's arm
yeah i i really did not understand
jessie j's response but all i know was
that she was
hella overcompensating for like
something that she thought she did wrong
right and i don't know if i'm unique in
this but like this is just like a
prime example of like why i don't stand
nicki minaj like i feel like she's
always taking an opportunity to like
start a fight with someone
and this was just like so unnecessary
like okay if you really felt that
strongly that you needed to correct
the narrative which is like not a big
deal like if people thought but i
understand you want your story out there
i just felt like she came like so hard
at jessie j like for literally no reason
yeah and it just makes it hard to be
like a nicki minaj fan and she's just
like
she's really not a woman who supports
other women yeah
i agree with you though knowing that
she's team unique like i definitely
want it changes things i i just want to
you know keep that in mind
you know it's true because it really
proves that you have like a very strong
logical reasonable head on your
shoulders right but i don't understand
like okay so
say jessie got the timeline wrong or
someone told her something to make her
feel better about the song that she
wrote
i am sure that both of the way that
these two women experience it are both
true right there's a label involved they
want to keep artists
jessie said was in any way disrespectful
to nicki minaj so she could have like
cleared up she could have cleared the
air and been like oh my god that's not
how it even happened like the label said
this and that
just so funny how you know this all came
to be right it didn't unless they just
unless nicki minaj just doesn't like
jeffy
and that's a possibility also it is kind
of crazy that like this song was so big
nicki minaj and ariana grande are
sitting and they've collabs so many
times and it is
it was like a little bit random that
jessie j was on the song 100
and i thought oh for sure jessie j wrote
the song ariana wrote the song and
ariana's done an interview basically
being like i can never sing that song
and she is like saying it so many times
because it was so popular
so just knowing that like this iconic
literally one of the best songs of the
last 10 years
is so deeply despised by everyone who
has been a part of it and now it's like
riddled with controversy
that makes me sad and i just really felt
like this was so
unnecessary of nicki minaj and it's just
like i feel like
if she doesn't really make music a lot
anymore so every time i'm hearing about
her she's just like starting a fight
with someone and it's like
like leave jessie j alone like you are
the queen of rap and like jessie jade's
like barely hanging on
to her relevancy by a thread like leave
her alone like i don't know it just felt
like so unnecessarily like mean girl
i agree i totally agree even though like
i think jesse is probably the highlight
of jessie j square where is like nikki
and ariana have
have many highlights and this is just
one of them but so to take
to take away from like the one big one
for her
a great it's so sad totally and jesse i
don't know why
it never really happened for jessica
that's what i was about to say i think
that she is so
talented i love a lot of her music she
doesn't really put
actually she just put out a song called
i want love and it's so [ __ ] good she
obviously
does bad management like she there's
something about jessie j that like the
world refuses to like
accept yeah but like she didn't really
help herself when she like performed
at like an award show within she like
sat the whole time because she had a
broken foot and like she bedazzled her
cast and like for me that's really all i
remember about jessie j
actually if you're ever wondering like
why do jackie and claudia think that
jessie j is so underrated
you must go watch the videos of her on
youtube in that um
really big chinese talent show yeah it's
like this show in china that like people
who are already famous go on but it's
like
great to go on to like expand your
chinese audience and she won first of
all
and she has like four or five
performances um
she did a bunch of whitney houston i'm
trying to remember which song she did
whatever literally you've never heard
vocals like that in your life it's so
spectacular
she's so talented and she writes amazing
songs but there's something like about
her that just won't take off it doesn't
hit and doesn't stick
i know even like she's super relevant
like with her relationship with chad and
tatum like
she really has all the makings of like
what should be a huge pop star but
there's something about it that just
doesn't work
yeah and that makes me sad because i'm a
big fan of hers
same and i just like with this whole
drama i do stand with jessie j
like you're right this is the highlight
of her career like ariana and nikki like
couldn't care less about it
which i get because they're accomplished
in their own way but like it just really
felt like really unnecessary of nicki to
come at her like this
yeah i agree like it's been how many
years and she's still doing interviews
about it like
oh my god stop i'm gonna cry what do you
mean it's like he's not like
no so it was just kind of
yeah the whole thing was really sad and
then like the the saddest part was
jessie's jay's
response to nikki's like yeah should we
get dinner
well no no like all these like a whole
essay on instagram with like memes like
she was just
overcompensating so hard because like
she obviously doesn't want to
mess up this one great thing like in her
career yeah
yeah and it makes me really sad yeah i
felt sad after
just the whole synopsis it was honestly
like a really
emotional journey this whole thing yeah
and we're in like
what is a really great iconic song she
might have let you hold her hand at
school
but i'ma show you how to graduate
now i don't need to hear you talk the
talk just
show me what your mama gave you
do
oh
hey like and then jessie j hits oh no
ariana hits that note wait who would i
mean they're all hitting notes
they're hitting everything no i think
it's jessie j it's so good
yeah i will actually will not let this
story
overtake the legacy of that song i will
not i will
not will i no no no she will not i'm not
will i am i'm will i not
so i think we should move on before yes
no i'm getting like sweaty sorry
are you ready for our next story yeah
rihanna reacts to becoming a billionaire
with the best three-word response so
last week forbes revealed
that rihanna's estimated net worth is
about 1.7 billion dollars
she's almost a two-time billionaire yeah
right like you're a little late then
you're seriously seven point seven
i understand not 700 million late i
understand i wanted to make the
announcement at like 1.0 because like
you know it's still touch and go maybe
the stock market has a bad day
but like 1.1 1.2 like why they wait to
1.7
yeah she is now the richest female
musician in the world and the second
richest female entertainer
only behind oprah winfrey that's crazy
because like i don't even think of her
as a musician anymore
i know when paparazzi approached her and
asked her what it meant to her to be a
self-made billionaire
she only had three words to capture how
blessed she is
she said quote god is good oh
i mean this is obviously not shocking at
all because fenty beauty is so popular
so is savage xfenty like
she's a million endeavors that are just
so sickening
and i just feel like this is happy and
sad news because
it's happy we're so happy for rihanna i
just feel like this sets us back even
more
no music in the music department and i
actually think it's inherently possible
like we will
never get new music and like i think we
as a society like have to come to grips
with that and if we get one great
but i just think our expectations should
be really like that's when it comes to
music
yeah our expectations should be zero
really yeah so we'll only be pleasantly
surprised if it happens but not
disappointed if it doesn't
yeah i agree so when i heard this news
i'm like that's amazing but we're one
step further from new music
exactly i feel like but it's so
important
it's also always like doing collabs
still you know
yeah always blending her talents seconds
from wallin
that is also i think one of the most
underrated songs like ever
so [ __ ] good and it's like what does
paul mccartney do unclear because you
don't really hear him but happy that he
got to hang out with rihanna and kanye
yeah speaking of kanye donda is still
not out yeah
but kim went back to mercedes-benz
stadium so all is right in the world
right and the kids were there and she
was all dressed up yeah her outfit
wasn't as sickening this time
but it was kanye fied yeah oh you know
i liked it just as much as i liked the
other one in the sense that like it was
she was doing something she was wearing
a ski mask
yeah no but she was doing something it
wasn't for me okay until you like you'll
be wearing it in two years for sure
that's how the world works
for sure so i was just glad to see them
all together like even if donda
you know whenever it comes i'm just
they're giving us like
co-parenting
moderate family vibes you know yeah and
they're giving us
hope you know what i recently i feel
like they could get back together i feel
like they might be i think
they could too i feel like they might
realize that really there's no one
on their level and that it's not
the grass isn't greener i actually think
that's entirely possible as well
you know what i recently rewatched as in
reassignment yesterday um
airplane karaoke with kanye and james
gordon it's
so good so good it's so impressive like
i always forget about sunday service
because they haven't done in a while or
maybe they have but like kim's not
storing it
it's literally the most impressive thing
yeah so good
if you're ever feeling down like i
should really make a youtube playlist of
like things i watch when i'm down that
includes jessie j
and all of her chinese talent show
performances it includes that video of
beyonce singing in the back of the car
includes a couple fifth harmony covers
before they were famous before they
started really seeing music lego house
so good red taylor swift so good um
the making of getaway car the bridge
like there's just so many youtube videos
i could
i could list off caitlin and sean's
engagement i don't watch that anymore
just out of respect but i used to watch
it all the time
one of my favorites but you know she's
in a better place maybe if we get a
televised version of their engagement
i'll have something to replace them with
have one televised
not tell like we have a video of jason
and katelyn's engagement because he's
recording for the podcast yeah i'm
pretty sure it is okay are you ready for
our next story which is about
relationships so it's a great segue
it's a great segue into my best
relationship the one with my dog
theo oh my goodness and if you guys
listen to the show you know that our
dogs are a huge part of our family and
that's why when it comes to keeping theo
and brutal safe happy and secure we knew
that the halo collar was the only
collar we would use it is the only smart
system with a collar that trains
tracks and protects your dog so they can
safely run free
you can create halo fences by walking
the perimeter with your collar or at the
touch of your finger with the halo app
you can train with natural simple
profound communication via the custom
feedback you set for your dog
it can even include your voice they also
offer location and status you can stay
connected to your dog and see how
they're doing from activity and safety
status anytime you want
the gps works with yourself without cell
or wi-fi and you can create up to 20
fences instantly
they included 21-day training programs
that set you up for success
check out their 90-second video on
shophalocolor.comtoast to see how easy
it is
for me personally the gps is like an
absolute game changer because when i
became a dog mom and they're like you
have this dog have the chip
and you found out that like the chip
doesn't carry gps it's like what's the
point of the chip
so the halo color is a great great thing
because it's just so important like
especially if you're traveling with your
dog
just it's always good to be safe um take
advantage of their special limited
time introductory offer and save 20 on
your halo caller
by going to shop halo caller dot com
slash toast
that's shop halo collar dot com slash
toast save 20 but you must use
collar the site slash toast to get that
20 off
shop shop halo caller.com
toast check it out thank you so much
claudia
it's a pleasure are you ready for our
next story a bit of relationship news
yeah
yeah
yeah tyler cameron and girlfriend camila
kendra split
after eight months tyler is crazy
c and his girlfriend have split after
eight months of dating and only one week
after he called her his soul mate
pitched
says lauren that's what i was thinking
he literally just said she's a soulmate
i'm watching up inside
do you think that the timing is like at
all suspicious like what is this
10 days after he sat down with me for an
hour and he sat down with theo
i think he saw like what his life could
be and he was like i don't know if i
could have this with camilla
yeah because theo belongs to claudia
i just think i think the timing is worth
pointing out yeah
um a source for page six that things
took a turn which is awesome i really
want to know what happened which is a
weird thing to say
which that's a weird thing because
literally they were on watch wrappings
live together
one week ago soulmate what the word
soulmate was used
though and if we're finding out now it
must it couldn't have been yesterday it
must been a few days ago
yeah but he also uh it couldn't have
been that much different if he like they
were together a week ago
but he also said it must have been
really abrupt though you know like
there's no but i'm saying if
this article is out today there's no way
they broke up
this morning like this must be a few
days old yeah and he was on what happens
if a week ago so this literally must
have broken up
three days after watching also spotted
in jacksonville jumoi posted
with a blonde girl all over him so it
looks like he had a single weekend
so they probably broke up late last week
but i will say just
like maybe he used the word soulmate he
also called matt james his soulmate so
like maybe he could still say like
camilla is a soulmate maybe he thinks
you can have a lot of soulmates yeah
maybe he's one of those people things
like your friends are your soulmates
yeah i mean
they're friends but things took a turn
just quickly
that usually we don't get that we get
scheduling we get this we get that
yeah no and it's like over the course of
time like we're questioning like did
they break up
they unlike this photo yeah they
unfollowed each other but like
they are broken up like 100
it's hard it's over i wonder why like
when you're both so stunning what is
there to fight about
i don't know i lost ben
oh also i think he might need some
emotional support so if you wanted to
send theo down to his place
dr jacksonville that would be so sweet i
just kind of want to put some of the
rumors to rest
okay um i'm not wearing my ring today
because i forgot
so just i know everyone's like
constantly thinking like me and bad
thinking stuff forgetting to wear my
wrist
and it's just so crazy how like when i
don't wear my ring which is probably
fifty percent of the time people are
like
jackie's not wearing her rings like do
you watch the show no but like what
about the other fifty percent when i am
right right i'm usually pretty good but
like i genuinely forgot today also my
nails are so
disgusting i just don't think it's right
to put diamonds on these things my nails
are disgusting brittle i have had not
one opportunity i haven't gotten a
manicure in so long my nails are
i might have to go today because i just
it will
it will improve my mental health if i
stop looking at these hands no i mean i
literally left the house yesterday and
walked around the block went to two
different places to try and get my nails
done
closed that's really upsetting you know
i was saying to ben this used to be the
city that never
slept recently everyone's sleeping quite
a lot like it's no longer this like
hustle bustle
the other night i was like wasted tried
to get mcdonald's like 2 a.m like they
were closed
mcdonald's it was wild no they're
sleeping
you know everyone's asleep i'm just
saying wake the [ __ ] up [ __ ] frank
sinatra would be
did he say a city that never sleep yeah
i wanna
wake up in a city
that doesn't sleep yeah he would be very
disappointed he is
like shaming you wake up are you ready
for a fifth and final story
is it the final story
[Music]
beautiful stunning yeah what is it
renee zellweger supports and and stead
during supercar gala for first public
event as a couple
you and i haven't spoken about this
because we haven't i think i did it with
olivia who i knew would be like so
interested in the drums
there is a lot to unpack here so first
renee zellweger is showing support for
her boyfriend who is ant
and stead who used to be married to
christina and stead
who used to be married to tarik el musa
who was currently engaged to heather ray
young
okay so that's what you need to know
that's the back story and renee
zellweger
a-lister oscar-winning judy garland
judy garland the couple used to be
married to kenny chesney for
11 seconds yep the couple stepped out on
saturday night to attend the radford
motors gala at the lion air museum
in santa ana california lion with a y
i just whatever i think of lion air i
think of the orphans and children and
widows
of course um they unveiled their new
coach built what sports car whatever
okay other important factory
in photos shared by real housewives of
orange county alum
lydia mclaughlin and her husband doug
the pair smiled along
zell weger and anstead in formal attire
for the big night
so unclear i mean clearly lydia and her
husband were at this event
unclear if this is you know a dynamic
foursome
definitely not or lydia is a fan and
asked to take a picture or maybe like
hanging out and is going to be on the
cover of the next seasonal issue of
noblemen yeah that the hottest magazine
in all of orange county that really
could happen
um i'm just really in shock over the
whole thing like first of all
renee zellweger dating a reality star
it's shocking and it never becomes less
shocking
he's actually not a reality star he's a
british
tv host okay that's what does he host
reality shows
no like these car shows like i don't
know he's not a reality star okay
realities are adjacent
yes because he was married to christina
for 11 seconds yeah
so just renee zellweger dating him like
when you get
such an a-lister and it's kind of
reminding me of like zoe de chanel and
the property brothers
yes oh my god that's gorgeous which at
its time was shocking and now it's just
a fact of life no not for me i'll still
never be surprised by it
they're so like they've been together
for so long i don't think there's any
you know
issues there so it's just like a fact of
life like zoe de chanel dates the
property brothers
and married no okay the other one got
married like this to me is you know like
nick vile dating january jones like it's
shocking ggsd dating tyler cameron
it's shocking stuff so i haven't had a
chance to just come here and say that
well
i have more layered information for you
if you're ready for it
so obviously this whole thing is so
weird because how you go like this is cr
this is
connecting heather ray young to renee
zellweger we know that it's just a crazy
turn of events
but what's even crazier and i saw it on
tick tock this girl did a huge deep dive
because she too was like
obsessed with the layered-ness of it all
did you know that aunt anstead has a
sister correct
i might be getting this wrong but it's
somewhat of the same genesequin
or or it's either his sister or his
sister-in-law
started a podcast a little while ago
with heather ray young
yeah and then
one of them dropped off and no they
obviously don't do the podcast together
anymore i think it's
heather dropped off that can't be yeah
yeah like it's twisted
that can't be right hold on let me find
the tick tock because this girl did she
did like a
huge in-depth doing your tick tock
theory it's like no offense i remember
there's a theory book about the titanic
because of your tick tock theory
and they literally squashed that rumor
that you start
that you said of like with the uh oh
they did in one [ __ ] second what'd
they say
which rumor were there's a lot of like
the one that i was saying was that it
was like a conspiracy because the
federal reserve or something okay they
didn't even mention that that's how
that's how low level that theory is but
the one where they swapped out the
olympic
for the titanic to get the insurance
money for the olympics
i didn't say that and they the guy was
just like why wouldn't you just start a
fire if you want to sink the ship as
opposed to killing
a thousand people okay i can't find the
tick tock but i will
it's just like really full of pertinent
information you really need to start
questioning these tick tocks
oh i disagree wholeheartedly i think
they're incredible
and like i feel like what also comes to
mind is that
guy who started that rumor about kanye
yeah he was that guy's just like a [ __ ]
starting youtuber like who does that for
fame
i just we really need to start
questioning these tick tocks so i'm
questioning it
is this it i'll find it but okay um and
i'll post it on our
reels okay cool it's worth
it's worth going down snitches and stead
okay let's have
tv instead because there's so much tv
recap that like it's oozing out of me
let's just start
playing and simple with the real
housewives of potomac from last night
how does that work that's a great idea
our tv recap segment is brought to you
by purple doesn't it seem like the
world's against us from getting a good
sleep
good night's sleep this time of year
talk about the warm weather like
literally setting me up for failure it's
just not working
but when you have a purple mattress you
can sleep cool and comfortable no matter
what the world throws at you
that's because only purple mattresses
have the grid it's a unique ventilated
design that allows air to flow through
to help you sleep cool even when it
feels like a thousand degrees out
and the grid is amazingly supportive for
your back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders neck and hips no matter how
you sleep
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything the grid bounces back as you
move and shift
so you never get that i'm stuck feeling
like you do with a memory foam it's true
there's like a visible difference in not
only how you move
in a purple mattress but also the
cooling technology like basically
everything i purchased for my bed from
the mattress the pillows the sheets
everything it's just with the cooling
technology in mind and i didn't think
i'd be able to find a mattress that had
that technology available
but your girl who sweats at night is
being taken care of i just got a new
purple mattress pillow and it's so
delicious and i thought i had like
decent pillows happening no i have to
try to switch over all my pillows it was
so
fantastic perfect firm to softness ratio
you can try your purple mattress risk
free with free shipping and returns and
they also offer financing
purple is comfort reinvented and right
now you'll get 10 off any order
of 200 or more if you go to purple.com
tmt and use the promo code tmt that's
purple.com
tmt promo code tmt for 10 off any order
of 200
or more purple.com tmt promo code tmt
terms apply thank you okay real house is
a potomac
literally that house is so sickening i
actually looked it up
because i'm like we should spend the
weekend at the estate
okay it's literally um the website's
broken like i could not find a rate if
my life depended on it like it's the
website's been down maybe so many people
were looking it up because of last night
oh maybe then it crashed
i have so many grievances with this
episode but the one that i
literally cannot get over is robin dixon
shoving mia out of her room not asking
but just telling
if anyone did that it's so disrespectful
but robin dixon like you don't
carry that much weight in this show like
you're barely hanging on to this cast by
a thread
be disrespectful she was so and the fact
that mia just took it because she
finally got on a good place with rob
with robin and gizelle and i think she
saw what it could be like to be on the
bad side
and she wanted nothing to do with it so
she just said okay but it's like robin
and giselle literally can't help
themselves when they were having
cocktails with me and they were all
really having a nice time and like they
came to an understanding and they have
an appreciation for mia
i was like wow how bad can robin and
gisele really be like if you're friends
with them it's probably fun and they're
probably funny and
you know it's a good time but like not
even in the next scene
they're just like they can't help but be
so mean about even like this like she
walked in in the gown and she's like
and giselle in her commentary it's like
is that the gown you wore to the strip
club because she said it
they literally can't get over there's a
stripper pole and they're like wow
you've never you've
obviously done that before like she's
been so honest about everything
her [ __ ] her meeting her husband at a
strip club she's literally
not been lied about right single thing
and they're just so
nasty like i literally this episode i
didn't think it was possible to hate
giselle and
and robin even more but i hate them so
much and i cannot
wait for wendy zen wen to rip
the [ __ ] into jesus somebody has to do i
can't believe that it's going to be
wendy who is the one who all of our
hopes and dreams
are relying on you know because i mean
after this episode and wendy really is
just like all over the place this season
i have no idea like
who is she who is she and it's like if
this were her first season i'd be like
oh
she's liberated but just in the context
of last season i'm just like
who are you and i like even though i
hate yourself she is
justified in her confusion about that
wendy because like literally wendy
showed up on that bus looking snatch
like that body suit that like showed her
hips
amazing who is this woman like she
really is acting
so different that it is confusing for
everyone i wonder if it's the theme of
the show i don't think it's because
there's a rumor about eddie so she had
her whole body redone i think i don't
know the timing is weird
i think it's the show like i think she
had one season i think she
thought she got good reviews and now
she's like i'm gonna be the next martha
stewart like
really i don't think that people use
those that those things used to happen
more often like
in the earlier days of real housewives
where like you know you do one season
and then all of a sudden your true faith
you know and like you have a big
brand that you're gonna launch i don't
think her first season was
you know acclaimed enough for her to
have that sort of
takeaway and i also think it's the fame
is like getting
to her a little bit i actually think
that like
this season i'm liking her more just
because she's less
up robin and giselle's ass but
this candle thing like i'm sorry i
cannot get on board like
i'm with your mom like throwing away
your doctorate and your political
commentating career to start a candle
line
that your husband finances like that's
just so cliche and i'm i just i'm sorry
like i
i can't get on board no not at all i
don't even think it's cliche i think
it's outrageous it's outrageous
and i've never and she doesn't even have
a passion for like owning her own
business she doesn't even know you like
you needed a trademark like it's not
like
this is a huge dream of hers it's like
every decision she's making in her
personal life recently makes
no [ __ ] sense yeah and it's so
contrary to who i thought she was so was
she
lying last season is she lying this
season like who is the real wendy so
giselle is asked asking a valid question
there
also the moment that really bothered me
the most was when candace was telling
everyone what rooms they would be in on
the bus like into the microphone like i
can't stand her can't dis
like i she's so oh my god
i fast forward through her personal
scenes because me too i do have to
protect my mental health
she just had so much like she was so
excited to like tell
karen you planned the trip what do you
mean like the producers put your name on
it so
totally she was so excited to tell karen
and wendy and um
the other girl with who the other new
girl oh
they're going to form an alliance and
the main house girls are going to turn
on each other the thing is that ascala
is a friend of robin
not for long which is a huge red flag
yeah yeah yeah next episode seems to be
good because they are finally having
like a dinner all of them or they're
going to talk about some stuff so
when ashley finally shows up ashley has
no the fiery baton no but it's like
it's she she just had a baton and she
set it on fire because
gizelle is the one who's supposed to
bring up the eddie rumors and so ashley
gave her
one minute to do so before she's gonna
tell wendy and that's why i [ __ ] love
ashley i love ashley so much she's
literally and even when and like i
it's [ __ ] candice who's like you gave
birth two minutes ago you're gonna come
on the trip it's like like you're
coochie
she's just so disrespectful like don't
you because she's ripped open like are
you kidding me like that's how we're
talking about childbirth it's like
that's how much
ashley takes her job seriously like and
you can see how attached she is to her
baby
she's wearing glam literally her newborn
baby's three days old gisele's coming
over to look at her baby she hates
gizelle and it's like
she's literally putting her child near
giselle even though she probably doesn't
want to
in full glam literally her coochie
ripped open and she that you she's such
a good housewife
she's such a good housewife she never
stops and she's such a good mom and she
and she'll probably bring the new baby
with her and like she will do it [ __ ]
all and she will
throw that fiery baton into the house
and
she showed up for one [ __ ] day no i
agree like i just
and maybe it wouldn't be if like i
didn't dislike candice so much but like
everything she does bothers me like oh i
forgot to invite ashley to the girls
night oh i forgot to invite ashley on
the girls trip like just
if you don't like like just be honest
like no that i hate when people are like
nasty and then they're like
who me he's like no at least be nasty
and [ __ ] own it
own it lisa a hundred percent so it was
just like a really frustrating episode
because
i'm like i feel like i'm on this island
alone with karen and you
like and ashley yeah and they're just
they don't have enough people on their
side
no but wendy is coming to the island and
she's going to karen's hometown and if
she'll make she's
oh that's funny that was really smart if
gisele makes fun of karen in her
hometown one more time like
i can't it's so disrespectful like you
blink and you might miss it like
so rude everything that comes out of
gisele's mouth is so judgmental and then
she's like
genuinely confused why people don't like
her yeah oh my god that was so rude
everything is just a dig a dig a dig
yeah so i want ray to live i want ray to
pay his bills
shut up shut up like she's literally
hanging on to this
one thing that karen did at the reunion
which was talking about things everybody
already knew
when gisele has literally built her
housewife's career off the bones of
other people's
personal business she brings up all the
rumors she brings up all the cheating
she brings up everyone's personal life
everyone's husbands everyone's children
that is literally who she is and karen
did it once rightfully so
rightfully so karen did it one [ __ ]
time and giselle thinks that like
literally she's owed
by an apology for the rest of her life
with a fact with receipts
and giselle lives in a glass house she
throws stones every [ __ ] episode she
gets
one stone in her window and it's world
war three it's so hypocritical like how
can she not like see herself
i it's she it's reminding me of dorinda
where it's like i'm having a hard time
even watching this person be
so for jorinda it was like so misbehaved
and for
gisele it's so hypocritical it's the
true definition of hypocrisy it's
infuriating and last night was no
exception like just the way they were
sitting there does anybody want to
apologize
shut up yeah i want you to apologize and
karen is just so mature and she's a
queen her answers are
perfect are you talking to me so good
she's so composed like she doesn't let
yourself get her
she's really sure it affects her you
know because they are
so [ __ ] mean to her so me but i'm
like a role model when karen walked onto
the bus in her
stunning pink coat stunning like she
looked amazing and giselle and robin
were like now that's
like what are you talking about poncho
poncho
one word poncho her coat was so pretty
like
okay first of all even if it wasn't like
to make someone fun of someone in front
of their face but like
again look in the mirror poncho but for
giselle to even
make the slightest remark grimace
about someone else's style whether that
be interior design
whether that be personal style fashion
choices is
literally the definition of hypocrisy
no it's it's the pot calling the
kettlebell sadness
and you know what i also find like crazy
but i don't mind it it's like
giselle has gotten ripped apart for her
style like every single
season after season like i think even
when she thinks she's it's getting
better like it's actually just getting
worse and i just can't believe that she
hasn't just like brought someone in to
fix the problem
yeah maybe like she just can't hide bad
taste like
you just can't yeah or maybe she's just
someone who she thinks has good taste or
maybe
like you know she just writes that off
as like you know haters but like the
haters actually have a really valid
point like you need a stylist
yeah no but like she would hire the
wrong one still totally yeah
um so that's it it's actually turning
out to be a very good season and i feel
like this
wendy stuff is really going to blow [ __ ]
up like i can't wait yeah i'm like sad
for that wendy's family has to be drug
through the mud but like
if that's what it took for her to see
like who giselle really is
then it had to happen yeah and i'm sorry
i'm sorry too
okay let's talk about love island let's
i have literally nothing happened last
night there was a recoupling
but basically one couple went home and
it was just the
america voted who their three favorite
couples were andre and trina who like
are actually like both open to
delving more into whatever this might be
even though there's only like a week
left
um olivia and corey obviously and who
was a willing cara
boring william that's a lie will and
carol
they were in the bottom and they haven't
done anything to come out of the bottom
i think they got less votes i think it's
rigged
100 percent they got less votes because
did you see their faces i'm i guess two
episodes behind me they were shocked
because cash still hasn't gone home
and oh i don't know who um andre is i
don't think is he he's a new brazilian
guy
who came in for olivia okay i met him
yeah um
and also one other thing oh i thought
that cory was going to choose bailey
what let me guess
jeremy got her yeah and jeremy was in
the bottom with literally no [ __ ]
effort whatsoever jeremy was in the
bottom
with this other these two other couples
and literally like we're like we're
saving jeremy
again but this other couple full of new
people who you like literally don't even
need to meet because they left
she basically was she like very outright
said like i'm not feeling a connection
with this guy so
arielle was like who do you think has
the least potential here as a couple and
they had to say this couple because
she literally said she didn't like him
like okay so of course jeremy got saved
and so did um charlie and alana who i
love alana oh my gosh oh and they're a
couple now yeah okay
because i saw them on their way to
couple dumb so people just think that
like
charlie's really toxic and like he used
cash to get from casa moore into the
house
but i don't really see it that way like
i actually think he's a genuine guy
like i've been reading a lot of like
reddit and like tweets and people just
like are not here for charlie they think
he's like you know a user
i don't really get that vibe like he's
allowed to explore like he was really
into cash
when they got back to the house cash was
so clearly caught up with cinco
like of course it would turn him off and
i think he was justified in exploring
other things and he was into a land and
he chose atlanta
and by the way cash wasn't even mad the
second she got sent home she's
packing her thing she's like i can't
wait to see cinco like it was always
cinco so
why are we mad at charlie for sending
her home when cash is literally here
saying it was always cinco
yeah i agree i watched the breakup or
the attempted breakup go down i
felt like he was pretty honest like and
i don't you know
i don't really know what he i don't know
what more people want from him yeah
so but what's so funny is like the girls
are so hypocritical and like nobody
[ __ ] calls him out like first of all
olivia
with corey like watching her try and
talk about like how she wants to salvage
their
you know their love when there's nothing
there whatever fine she can say what she
wants but wait
so he's into bayley and he's talking to
bailey and having a lot of conversations
with bayley
and they're like how do i know if he's
disrespecting me and cash was like if he
um kisses her or if he like lies about
something
and then literally olivia and he she's
like is corey's head turning his corey's
head turning
then those two new guys come in and
olivia goes into the confessional she's
like my head is turned and it's like
imagine if corey acted like that when
bailey showed up
and she like she kisses him like so
quickly and like
just everything she's saying is like if
corey did those things
it would be like over a lot of these
girls are literally the definition
you either die the hero or live long
enough to become the villain because
towards the end of cash's time they're
like she was starting to be like a
little hypocritical justin like the way
she did with charlie and like she
literally
did things with charlie that she was mad
at cinco for doing like it was just
becoming like a little obviously so
charlie
tries to communicate and charlie said
this he's like you're all about
communication but i tried to communicate
with you then we got up and walked away
and like so charlie says like i don't
want to continue further and
cash can't handle it can't handle it and
then literally the next day is like
charlie says i mean cash
says to charlie you can tell me anything
yeah no she was
but she was unraveling in the charlie
thing most i think probably because she
was like still just like
upset about cinco but i actually think
that's why i think it's perfect
timing that she left because she's
beloved she they booked her flight home
she had a layover in dc
cinco met her in dc they met up she
missed her connecting flight she went
home with him and had family dinner with
his family like
that ended the way it was supposed to
end she got a storybook ending and i
think like people were
really sad that she left but i think
literally a perfect time could not have
come fast
because it was starting to sour it was
starting to just be like
you're saying things and doing things
that are miscon like misaligned like
yeah
it was pretty time and now you're saying
that so-and-so can go talk to so-and-so
but then like you're so upset
and then like you were just like saying
and doing like the exact opposite things
and i think a lot of the girls are
guilty of that
so now it's like olivia's kind of
the last og who's like still relevant
like trina's og but she's so quiet and
she's like so stunning and perfect like
i i can't i don't have a bad word to say
about her like she should win even
though she has
no connection with this guy just because
like they deserve it like she's been
through a lot on this show and
she should went home like a thousand
times but she's sticking down she has
such a positive attitude and she's such
a good friend like i just love her
no i love her but olivia is like see
what's happening to olivia is what would
have happened to cash if cash hadn't
gone home
i'm just starting to really like
roseanne hernan i think everything she
says is fake and
now that all the fan favorites literally
11 people had to leave for olivia to
become the main character
and she's just like talking and she's
just like so annoying like
like she just like is feeling the main
character energy but it's like shannon
had to go home josh had to go home sing
about to go home cash had to go home
literally a million people had to go
home in order for you to like get this
position
for you to shine she's like not me in a
love triangle like shut
up she's talking like cash like
like someone dm this to me and i really
started to notice it like and i guess
it's
like it used to happen to me at camp
like when i would be with my friends and
like there was this one girl
who was latin and she would like always
say these latin things and i started
like pick up on it
and you definitely when you are with
people a lot start to talk like them but
she's literally cloning
catch's persona not me being in a love
triangle oh
like that's what she's gonna do she says
ew
500 times a day oh my god so she's like
literally skinning cash and wearing her
like it's crazy and so i'm just starting
you know i really dislike her
still won't win like i'm really
concerned now about who's going to win
so i cannot
it cannot be willing there was no way to
know that josh and
shannon would have to leave and for a
million like of course for personal
reasons like it's so devastating it's
the most sad story of
like imagine being away and like it's
just horrible horrible but also for the
continuity of the show it kind of really
[ __ ] things up because
i think their biggest mistake there was
like this the episode that i was like
that i played out for you where florida
went home amy and wes went home
and someone else over oh um isaiah yeah
so randomly they sent four people home
when amy and wes are still together and
she like did a story that she's moving
to denver like they're legit
florida had hard connections with two
guys in the villa
and i say it was like a man about town i
don't understand why they did that
because ever since then i just feel like
the composition of the group like was
never the same yeah and then they just
like kept sending people and they keep
sending people home who are at the dawn
of connection and it's like okay we
can't say we're connected because we met
yesterday yeah but like how about the
people who have been here for like
30 days who are still single trina
jeremy olivia yeah no i agree that's
like a kind of fault in the show that
it's like it's
built and it's designed to keep the ogs
and most of the ogs
they're like this season they haven't
been able to they had their time and
they've had a million connections
jeremy had trina he had um amy he had me
yeah he had bayley he had ever like he
had um the other girl from
jenny oh my god yeah like
he had oh man genevieve dm'd me like
starting a fight like
it was twisted i didn't respond because
i'm like why am i fighting with this
like 22 year old but she like i'm always
just recapping
love island on my story and she put up
this like picture with her in cash
i mean with her in cinco and i was just
like it was just like a confusing photo
like
i just posted a question i just posted
it with a question mark because i'm like
what does this mean like are they
why are they where are they together are
they together like
asking questions that she put up a
misleading photo and she i'm gonna read
it like it was so
like she was like attacking me and i'm
like no it was out of here i didn't even
tag her like i don't even know how she
found it
it was out of control because you didn't
say anything you just asked a question
oh here she said
we got voted off together we're like
brother and sister don't try to make it
seem like something that's not
bestie i want cash to get her men's too
like you're the best seem like something
it's not like you're the one who posted
the photo that's misleading first of all
second of all like don't call me bestie
like i i've never met you
no i totally agree and also i cannot
wait to stay on beef with me like
another pet peeve of mine which love
island had brought to light and i just
want to say
oh no not even that but i want to say
shannon and josh when they went on their
one-on-one shannon called him a man i
just want to thank oh my god i noticed
that
i want to thank shannon for that because
i noticed that too
it meant so much to me but another pet
peeve of mine and just life in general
is when people are like we're like
brother and sister
especially when you met two [ __ ]
weeks ago like brother and sister have
spent their whole like
no so anyone who says we're like brother
and sister no we're like
when it's like what's going on between
you and jared oh he's like he's like my
brother
well is he your brother or can you [ __ ]
him they're it's
clear as day so especially since they
met two weeks ago like
that my pet peeve radar is off the
charts off the charts
yeah we're like we met two weeks ago oh
my god i can't so
so who went home last night was um
i kind of casey and ellie like there's
and la you could really skip last
night's episode
it was like it was two hours i was
shocked so i think that valley is coming
up i don't know who's gonna win i feel
like they're gonna
have this they're gonna try and make it
olivia and corey because for some reason
people don't like will and kira oh
willing cara had a date last night
and everyone was like are you gonna ask
her to be your girlfriend are you gonna
ask my girlfriend he was like no and he
didn't
he's like i'm not into labels like i
want to see what happens on the outside
before i ask her to be my girlfriend
would you show me do it because i'm
falling for you it's just like
like being someone's girlfriend is not
that big of a deal it's not like an
engagement yeah she was like really
weird
kyra was literally trying so hard to
pretend like she wasn't upset about it
but all the girls were like
before the date they were like do you
think do you think do you think and she
was like i don't know i don't know
and then when she left olivia was like i
actually just spoke to will and he said
he's not going to ask her so they were
like eek
then when she came back they were like
tiptoeing around it and
she was like no it's fine like she's
obviously upset but like she's just
she's just like a pick me girl like
she's like they're the weirdest couple
when she
people don't like them when shannon and
josh got back from their one-on-one and
they
pan to will and kira's faces it was such
sour grapes from them like
they can't win no and now that shannon
and josh are gone like they think that
it's the will and kira show like they're
trying so hard to be extra cute like
they don't know how to be cute i don't
know who can win because here's the
thing olivia and corey
i don't think people like them i think
people see through like the charade
excuse me and will and kira for some
reason like they've done nothing wrong
like people just don't like they're
extremely unlikable so honestly when
ariel said america's couples have voted
and the first person that came out of
her mouth was andre and trina this like
random couple he just chose her because
he was going to choose olivia and olivia
chose corey and or corey chose olivia
and it was like two girls left and he
just chose trina i guess like he thought
she was nice like
for no other reason but like i just want
trina's actually now that if you look at
it like
from a glance like she's been through
the most on the show and she's really
held
her head up high with dignity and she's
a good friend and she was
i think she deserves to win like not
even with andre i agree we should be
able to vote for a solo player we should
be able to vote for shannon and josh
we should up until this point they put
the entire show on their back i agree i
was thinking that too but i don't think
they'll do it
i just think they should i think so too
i think so too
and the show has a visible difference
without them
yeah now the other things i watched over
the weekend was love is blind after the
alter reunion okay
and it was so atrocious like you really
don't need to watch it but it was funny
just to like see everyone back in the
saddle it's so
scripted like update is like amber and
barnett are still engaged
amber literally i'm sorry they're so
married
he sold his house to pay off they made
it seem like
her student debt and now they're living
in amber's apartment with a roommate
but um lauren hamilton's husband cameron
hamilton
said on instagram q a like the editing
made it seem like it was for her
her student loans but it was actually
for his so i was like okay because i'm
like what is this man doing
they keep doing that yeah they did that
for during the show and she spoke out
about it like
they did it's really wrong they did it
again because cameron was like it was
for his student loans
um but they just kind of have this
miserable life where like she
had a seizure she was diagnosed with
epilepsy so she's really concerned about
her health and she wants to have babies
burnett has like a checklist of things
he wants to be out of his apartment he
wants to make enough money he wants to
have their own house before they start
having kids
so they're having dinner at their
in-laws and she pulls um the
her mother-in-law barnett's mom's mom
aside and they're talking about this
timeline how it's like really bothering
her like
she's ready and like he's not and like
it's never going to be perfect like we
should just like start having kids
and basically the mom was like you know
he's the breadwinner
and in the bible you know he's in charge
and being a woman sucks like that's
literally what she said to amber
and amber didn't even like flinch it was
the weirdest conversation
so i do feel like at first i'm like you
know what this is such a weird couple
that ended up being cute the more i got
to know them
they're super toxic and she is
so scary like she is he
amber's not barnette is not allowed to
talk to jessica i like her so much
no you won't like her after the special
she's really toxic like but can i ask
you something don't these people don't
aren't they famous don't they get
instagram ads it makes no sense amber
has 1.5 million followers and i looked
at barnett's instagram he's doing a
million ads like that [ __ ] pays there's
nobody who needs to be living
as a married couple an apartment with a
roommate yeah and that like you have to
feel like your husband is the
breadwinner like she can work
no but like for the anniversary he like
made this video like because um cameron
um hamilton made a speech for lauren and
it was the whole premise of the show is
that they're throwing a two-year
anniversary party
for the two couples that got married so
cameron made a speech for lauren obvious
they're literally the best couple on
planet earth and ever
all's good perfect you could cry like
his speech he was crying it was just
stunning and everyone was like we want
what they have
and then barnett put together this
little video of like how he goes to work
every day he kisses amber because she's
still asleep and it was like supposed to
come out
it was supposed to be a cute video but
i'm like oh she doesn't work like that's
literally what i took away from the
video i need to go see if she's
yeah they're just their whole money
thing like it just feels really toxic
like
and jessica like the show ruined her
life like it did and she's like
literally i was the most hated person on
reality tv she moved to l.a she's a
boyfriend who's a surgeon he obviously
did not come because like she was not
going to subject him to this toxic why
did she come
um she must have gotten paid or she must
have really wanted to clear the air
because like she must not be this crazy
person
maybe the show got her at a bad time she
is still 34 and mark is still 24 i just
wanted to update everyone on that even
though two years have passed they're
still 34 and 24.
is that ben oh my god that's ben what
are you doing here
come in you can come in and sit we have
to finish podcasting
what a stalker oh my god showing up to
the studio hi
we're in the middle of podcasting um so
what was i saying before i was
interrupted by my husband oh it's twelve
o'clock
you were saying he's twenty-four she's
thirty-four oh yeah it's a show where he
came back on to clear her name and she
brought tiffany gifts for um for both of
the couples
and she was like avoiding amber and
barnett the whole time because she was
like afraid and then she goes up to
barnett to give it to him she's like i
just want to say
like sorry for everything like i'm
really happy for you guys he like
literally could not speak he was like
oh i'm sorry like i'm not allowed to
talk to you like and ran away so amber
is definitely like very controlling
do you remember that girl elsie yeah she
like had an initial connection with
barnett
but he said he didn't want to choose her
just like he didn't want to choose
jessica
turns out she dated mark i think i knew
that and like i'm literally testing my
mind
for six weeks and then he got a girl
pregnant and he was dating like 11 other
girls at the time
so amber's best friends with mark and
amber's just like taking up for mark
being mean to elsie and it's just like
showing like everyone who had a
connection with barnett
amber is gonna find a reason to hate now
yes what jessica did was inappropriate
but like they were on a tv show it was
two years ago like can we move past it
she apologized at the reunion amber got
her say
amber had her moment like you're so
disingenuous remember like
she had her moment she won't let it go
and it's just like i actually she
started crying like after barnett like
walked away from her like really
embarrassed her
she started crying there with her
tiffany bag of gifts and like didn't
have i just i did feel bad for her
then the whole drama with giannina
what's going on damien's her person like
giannine is so cringy like when she
talks like she's crying like in
lunch like he's my person her mom refers
to him as her son i'm like oh my god
they're so going strong they've been
together for two years
they got through him leaving her at the
altar so apparently when he was in la he
went to dinner with a bunch of
influencers left a restaurant holding
hands with francesca frago they said
they're just friends like why are we
holding hands like
we saw those pictures yes we reported on
them because we thought it was weird
then
she's in atlanta for a photo shoot the
same weekend of this
party and he invited her because he was
telling
us and like that he wanted to invite her
because she's a friend like why wouldn't
his friend
come and you know he wanted to clear the
air between her and giannina
he kind of made it seem like to
francesca like they had a future
and he didn't tell her what to wear to
the party because she showed up in a
crosstalk let's go on a few chair with
him
he's so beta like i couldn't figure out
i'm like he's handsome whatever
what's wrong i'm gonna be drives a porch
he's the definition of a beta [ __ ]
loser like i could not
stand him francesca's like on top of the
world no no she was obviously paid to do
the show like it was so scripted i don't
think she's like
sitting home waiting for damian to call
no literally it was so stupid and then
like
jeannina was totally blindsided she's
like why is this girl who like caused a
huge problem in our relationship
being invited and he was like walking
around the party with her like didn't
even like if giannita ever gets back
with him
she has literally no self-respect it was
so disrespectful but it was also staged
like i don't know what to believe like
right
it was good that's what i'm saying it
was like not a real reunion it was like
a waste of your time but it was funny
like to see everyone back together
especially like the people
like that girl um honestly i can't
remember any of their names like the
besides oh but diamond she was the star
of the entire show
she was just giving the best commentary
she's friends with a lot of the people
um
carlton did not show up the guy who left
her after she just expressed
a little frustration that he didn't tell
her he was bi
after engage getting engaged her so like
it was just misleading she wasn't mad
that he was bad she was mad that he lied
and he was going to go to the reunion
and had a conversation with lauren
hamilton
and blew up at her and then just decided
not to participate in the special
anymore it was really weird
and it felt bad for lauren because
lauren was like there as a friend lauren
could understand what he was going
through he's talking about like a lot of
biphobia in their community
and then he just like attacked lauren
and lauren was like
don't degrade me like because you're
upset like and then he just disappeared
so he never got to say his piece and
honestly
he may have made himself look worse than
before right and maybe if he came he'd
make himself look even worse
yeah yeah he should have never just
agreed to participate because i had
forgotten about him you know right
right um and so that's all i also
watched obx but i want you to watch it
so we can talk about it in depth is it
pertinent that i watch it it's really
good
oh wow except the last episode is the
longest episode and it just like
it's so stupid like i can't that's
exciting um
it's really good though like i think
you'll enjoy it so i just watched so
much tv this weekend
and i really enjoyed it now i feel like
i'm really fully caught up on everything
i'm so happy for you and like you're
back to being whelmed
yeah you know because you were
overwhelmed with the olympics and now
you're just back on track
um so we literally went so long we have
we have a meeting we've been waiting
that we have friday night for us so
we've got to go thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning shows the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
roles available as a podcast anywhere
podcast we found so spotify itunes
stitcher public video i have ready to
cast box
all the places so whenever we listen to
podcasts find out this morning tell us
leave a five star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are the
society season two
leave a comment on our most recent
instagram of the emoji of the light bulb
because we are constantly giving you
bright ideas have a great day everyone
bye
bye